- Hey.
- [Voiceover] Oh, shit.
What do I say?
Hey back, is that lame?
I mean, hey's nice and
simple, it's not creepy.
She's not going to go back
to her friends and say
"Oh my god, you'll never
believe what beard-o said."
- What?
- Hey.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] Ugh, yeah hey is safe.
But then what?
Then after hey you've got nothing.
Remember sweater day?
- Hey.
- Hey!
- [Voiceover] Where'd
that get you, genius?
Step it up.
Say something smart?
Oh easy, just say her name.
People love hearing their name.
- Nancy, Nancy, Nancy, Nancy.
Nancy.
- Yeah?
- [Voiceover] Oh, now she wants more!
- Umm, did you know you
could hear with your tongue?
- [Voiceover] No!
- I'm sorry can you speak up?
(laughter)
- That, that is funny.
That is funny.
Umm, you like jokes?
- You're a weird guy, Doug.
- Thanks.
- What was that all about?
- [Voiceover] Oh shit!
What was that all about?
(rock music)
- You look pretty, fax-y.
Yeah, that's a long number.
Sending that to England?